now go and disorder correct counting
handers come alright alright hands
because three of us we all have to make
sure we're taking turns talking three
people's will happen
hi I'm Greg come and yeah I really
prefer fect good so Tony is trees he on
Instagram he is he has a working
progress gaming channel it will be up
I'll get to his game shop second Andrew
movie source channel a Gore 7-eleven on
clear in Instagram Tony he introduced me
to injustice I found out today that
Andrew did beat the first injustice I
did right so there's a couple of
trailers out they were requested I took
a photo
shrill Spencer River he wants us him and
several people wanted shattered
alliances trailer there's a part 1 and
part 2 you to reach a couple minutes
long let's get to a gentleman all right
and I did I watched the whole movie of
injustice on YouTube I didn't actually
play with you but I did watch the whole
thing actually entertain them really
good story I got a really yeah yeah
through in my years fighting crime I've
learned one proof that every villain is
the hero of his own story
[Music]
boy
we're now oh [ __ ] that's a problem by
the truth and justice the battle never
end when is expect when there's no more
crime we
[Music]
virtual si happy
[Music]
Oh given enough a the world
I
and either with me or against me
we hope it was only a matter of time
I'll try to make it pay mer
Oh Oh Batman
[Music]
I want more let's watch market the
waiver well not just we don't have
another credit okay
narcotics and offi the dark side dinging
we know never gets old
though all right that's good a party is
why I want to see more come on I was
awesome then for mine boss
really
they couldn't see his good intentions
were leading them down a path of tyranny
and evil that's our greatest hero became
our greatest
Bruce instead of widening your circle of
trust nobody wins all my arrows mommy
the ruler man you need help don't we nut
is not that guy anymore
I get what you don't trust me you should
separate Guardian this ring means
something because me know what comes
next we both knew it'd come to this fate
will not spare you wish you had my
kryptonite anger
the Icicle - Hartfield whoa
[Music]
regime is making a comeback not while
I'm wearing this ring
[Music]
we both knew it would end this way baby
you gotta always melon with man Wow um
you know like I know I didn't actually
play a game but I'll say that watching
the whole movie on YouTube like the
whole bit when they took all the footage
put together it was so easy to watch and
I was really pull in I found it a very
entertaining intense story so it looks
like here that they're not combining the
earths they even kept the universes
right it looks like I'm just focusing on
the one world project we had to bring
over that Batman had to bring over here
are we on earth to earth 1 me yeah
sounds like on earth - right it doesn't
look like it's like we need to bring
over the people from earth 1 again no
and I go this looks like a completely
story just like 1 world to think about
what they do in the actual game is that
you have to fight like this three
players with like a certain character so
you get a jump out from different
characters to see the glory so that was
going to be dope like I think we saw a
lot of scenes from like acting beat'em
the actual in-game like a story mode so
it looks better I mean I love the flash
mantle of those everything yeah nothing
a lot of a theme for this to me was like
Redemption yeah I know in terms of like
obviously we got Green Lantern has to
prove themselves like know what hell I
fought through so I like it we're really
like carving out a lot of these
characters stories because like it they
were really interesting I mean obviously
visually this looks incredible but just
like these are actually interesting
stories we're seeing between reverse
flash and flash Green Lantern getting
his ring back Batman's struggle against
Superman Superman you know having to
live with himself and wanting to destroy
the world like it's it's scary to think
about a world where Superman wants to
kill every yeah and and seeing Superman
in that room with the red Sun like on
him like that was visually awesome
like Ken reminded me a little bit of
Superman - which Christopher Reeve when
they you know when he goes into the red
kryptonite
so kind of remind me a little bit of
that but just obviously a little you
know more updated visuals but again the
story intent fell just between Batman
Superman has got me oh snap but
everything else included it's like icing
on the cake are they that they've amped
up have all sorts of action and
everything they hands up everything all
the different I don't know what those
specific word is when you do like the
special the fatalities or whatever
they're glass yeah I think they're
usually like well it was more combat
more on my car but yeah he acts like the
x-rays realities for injustice whatever
those are they've really amped that up
that was insane but I really like that
they're continuing this story on this
the batter at the one more Superman's
back because or - yeah - because when
you think about the way the first one
ends it ends in a way where it does set
up at like not everything is good again
just because they've locked everyone
away and doesn't mean you know
everything's back to good again so it's
interesting seeing that it's like you're
watching the rise now is before you you
got introduced into it you were brought
from birth one - earth - where
everything's just fluffed up here it's
like okay good guys are back in control
everything's good Bruce Wayne he's
forming alliances with the people who
need to be close with but the bad are
still like no we need a we need to come
back we need to bring our alliance back
together you know we need to go any help
Superman out but like the cause of
refining corner of - yeah there's one
yeah I agree with that and also what I
like seeing - just a continuation seeing
like how crazy like what just happened
think about what just happened Superman
almost just destroyed the world though
seeing what they have to deal with like
lament like the mental state of their
best friend and the world's greatest
hero turning on them and and just
changing the Legion says like that it's
going to be interesting to see where
these characters are now after that
intense and stroke not only the ethical
struggles that mental sort of a lot
Superman and they still love super many
still there is and I mean I love the
line by Kevin Conroy Batman from our
greatest hero to our greatest that's how
he became our greatest enemy yeah that's
just says it all right there and I love
how the one of the opening lines is true
was how like every villain believes he's
a hero in his own stories true like it
seems like this is going to capitalize
more because I'm the first one with a
lot of mystery and intrigue in like this
because it's really fun to watch like oh
this guy's bad
this guy works for bad Superman you know
like that was fun to watch here it
really looks like it's going to be a
battle of philosophies as well you know
battle of like point of views clashing
with each other which is like something
that I think the comic book world is in
general capitalizing on but like
mainstream you know with like daredevil
Punisher Civil War battle Ike something
like the Batman V Superman that we could
be used and already I feel like I'm when
it comes to them having to choose the
sides I'm really interested to see like
how it starts up where what Batman
starts choosing yeah like we got a
little picture of like who is on his
team so far so it's going to see it's
going to be interesting to see who
Superman be into I also got to say to
some of the humor here like from Harley
Quinn's end and yeah it just it sounds
like the dialogue is really good like
the dialogue between Superman and Batman
that's a harp on Batman V Superman but
just the little snippets like I'm almost
like I like kind of like this style like
a lot better than Martha and some again
the dialogue seems really good I mean
like you said I couldn't even have
played the video game just watching the
movie the movie stuff in this in the
first video game it's so entertaining
the dialogue is good it's intriguing
it's compelling storytelling and you
really care about these characters even
though they are your favorite super it's
really it's really good stuff so I mean
this looks like it's following and going
into more it's going into like a darker
place we also a good equals do Empire
Strikes Back Godfather Part 2 they go
into deeper and darker plays a dark
knight that's darker they got that
mortal kombat gameplay so you got to
have like that really gruesome like um
gameplay where it's just like see
Superman knocking Batman in down
yeah he's brutal do they have all those
x-rays they just always get really
detailed I know they don't really like
their I like gory implied it's not like
fatalities like oh but they really know
how to make that game just like more
interesting with the move Cesco does
like this it's just when they ever
really work off the other engine like
there he has a game established and
they've been working on this for so many
years it's like this looks like way more
of a better game when it comes to being
just just like I'm in
I'm a next-gen right yeah it's like yeah
what it has to it took a long time
usually like certain games like this so
like start throwing them out quickly
just get a couple of new features with
this one it took a lot of year oh yeah
not only are they on though they working
on like all the gameplay but just like
the story wise it's just going to get so
detailed it is like well I'm watching an
actual movie like in-between three
fights I have I'm going to be able to
watch like a long clip more interesting
than like actually fighting and I agree
and I mean just looking at this little
shot right here of Darkseid like look
how much detail is put into everything
that's the face you can see the crack
that I mean this does not look like
something that was just done like in a
few months or even a year looks like it
was a couple years done it it's so it's
like just very very distinct and it's
got its own look even though it does
look like the dark side but it's just
incredible I love how detailed these
these video games are now like really
incredible Batman the Animated Series by
many is considered all like which is a
great television show for Aundre being
already animated show it's a great
television show and the games is where
we got to continue those voice actors
and those kind of you know takes and
interpretation on those characters so
from going from the television world and
then transferring those creators and a
voice actors into the video game world
all see and make sense what we're
getting such great story of his name's
Mike definitely one last thing I don't
have to say like they're always great
with DLCs like know a lot of great
characters in there because like more
combat you start seeing like lettuce
based and like alien totally why
different like really gruesome
characters so it's going to be
interesting with to see if they like
cool from different genres a guy want me
spawn oh man
murdering with spawn on this game games
nowadays they're a happy LCS like oh
here's the game jump on and get this
will be a DLC pretty soon get Darkseid
career like a donut minute but yeah
Julian's doing justice whereas
spider-man sure that make everyone happy
you were a Batman sure Anna and Iron
Fist Vidya let the hate flow good
faithful oh I got a do together from a
different company
yeah maybe this channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects follows
Tony on Instagram trees II and he is
he's also gaming channel sorry and he's
I'm holding you to it math game comes
out of May gotta have your channel up so
we can play this game together yeah my
better let's go I'll have enough Andrew
movie source channel talking movies some
theories on there too and a Gore son 11
on Twitter and Instagram
bring out the shadow Zack Snyder what
are you going to adapt this we want you
we all do